hi guys my name's camera chambers and
this is Taylor's never seen cut off my
hair it's gone so blue today I am
watching Heather's for the first time I
think this is just a movie about like
girls being catty to each other and so
it should finish the Golf Classic
and people wouldn't ask you to do it
without further ado the boots have it
Oh Tom has never seen okay why didn't
any of you guys tell me this movie was
about killing people
I thought it was about like girls being
mean to each other in high school this
was so much fun first I thought they
were like taking themselves very
seriously and I just was like thrown off
it took me like a good 40 minutes to get
really into this film and then once I
was into it I was into it I thought that
they were just going to get in fights
and I thought Veronica was like gonna
like be excommunicated from the popular
girl group and that she was going to go
off and like you know get revenge on
them somehow not in the way that she did
I so enjoyed all of them her name's
Heather and they don't refer to them as
like Heather Aitken Heather actions just
Heather they always know who to talk to
you rounded super funny I don't know
that it seemed super odd veronica is
hanging out with them she's like kind of
a dark horse on first glance fits in
with them but you're just kind of like
why are you hanging out with these huge
jerk bags why the scene in the cafeteria
has some of the best outfits I've ever
seen in any movie ever the lead Heather
calls another one of the Heather's of
pillowcase for forgetting something is
that a term are we just calling people
like a ransom word necklace I know this
was the 80s but pillowcase like now it's
snowflake that doesn't that doesn't make
any sense I've never heard that before
but I've also never seen any movie so
it's probably just me Veronica why are
you hanging out with them those girls
are the worst they're going around
asking if you inherited four billion
dollars a million
whatever then you found out the earth
was going to be shot down by aliens
two days later what we spend the money
on probably I would go buy a giant car
or like a bus then I would go hit up
every adoption in place in Chicago and
get all the dogs and cats and then I
would go drive out to the middle of
nowhere and like drive up a mountain and
just be on top of the mountain and oh I
forgot I'd stop for food I would get a
ton of food I would drive up to this
mountain and I would hang out a bunch of
dogs and cats for two days and just eat
a shit-ton and drink I'd get whiskey and
um die with friends who loved me for who
I think though they don't care that I've
not seen any movies they don't care
except for Gerald generals is big so
there's the character Martha who
everyone makes fun of she's the typical
character that gets me put up just
Martha it's her name so you obviously
you don't even have to see a picture of
her to know Martha is so much that gets
me from the part where Veronica forges
the signature of the jock asking Martha
out on a date sucks and it's very like
typical like you see this in all like
girl quick bully films but I just hated
it so sad the ending is freaking awesome
of this movie I adore it
I love the smashes them ponytail holder
I love going to ask Martha out on her
prom date and it's just really nice and
lovely also no one died at the end
except for a wall that's not sure
someone's I mean Justin explode but
basically no one died so the dumb jocks
like laugh at Martha I laugh her out of
the room and then two of them go up to
Justin Justin being Subspace JD - later
stars and scrubs and so behold adjusted
and they're like picking a fight with
him and I was like okay they are super
leg homophobic which I don't enjoy but
typical just jerks characters also still
thought the movie was taking itself very
seriously um the bed
JD crew got a gun and shoots both of
them with blanks but it's a real gun
Sydney shoot there's not much talk about
it if anyone else the parents are gonna
address me like the school board there's
a ton of teens with the school board
knows it didn't dress that this kid has
a gun like a real gun okay
the 80s I guess I mean that's just like
straight straight hair ISM but oh okay
no yeah carry on the main header goes to
a college party with Veronica Maine
Heather like sleeps with Paula Jude or
give him a blow job she doesn't seem
super into it
the Veronica's like no thank you and no
thank you
then Heather gets super Maddox this is
weird that's why it's a cult classic
though Jason like sneaks into her
bedroom at night would she like angrily
riding in her not here she's not weirded
out by it which I found pretty weird
this guy just like where did you get my
address how did you know where I lived
also hey hi okay then they sleep
together in her croquet Court and they
devised this plan that they're going to
make Heather throw up because Veronica
threw up at the party and so it's like
I'm gonna get back into my leg all right
here we go this is where this story is
going definitely definitely not going to
kill people
everyone has walked into each other's
houses in this movie which is odd when
they just walk into Heather's house
where are her parents I don't know
Veronica's like let's mix milk and
orange juice she'll totally throw up at
that no it's just creamy orange juice
like a 50/50 bar come on girlfriend good
step your game up a little bit but then
JD is like what was just Taylor and he's
was like Drano in a cup and she's like
haha very funny and then the kids and he
distracts her sexually
good news smartly Heather drinks it and
had a crashes through a glass table and
then they write a suicide note because
Veronica's great at forging things I
wrote what the fuck she died how did I
not know how is that not spoiled for me
most of these films
I see for Tara's ever seen I already
know bait hanging I guess not no I'm
always surprised I never know anything
but I wanted to give myself credit there
but I can't no credit were credited to
cook I just don't understand how I did
no I take it back
that did not deserve my hair you see the
school board talking and it's uh they
like how should we deal with this and I
was distracted the whole time because of
the one teacher who has butterfly
earrings and a cat pin like a giant
crystal necklace and her hair is
feathered she's the best I love her
Veronica make a lot of poor decisions in
this movie I'm not even necessarily
talking about like the debt I'm talking
about like the people he hangs out with
and the date she goes on one of the
Heather's is like hey I want to go on a
double date we need another girl please
come at this and she's like well I'm
kind of with JD but whatever Ando
whatever it's fine
not really how dating works I have some
people yeah you have to talk it out
first though make sure that all parties
involved are okay with the guys end up
getting drunk and end up cow tipping fun
so fun
reminds me of my high school but anyway
she leaves today goes to school the next
morning and find out that Kurt has been
spreading rumors about them having like
threesomes with her and Kurt and RAM and
it's gross and so rude high school so we
started rumors that I was pregnant and a
teacher approached me about it and I was
like hi I'm Jared I wasn't even allowed
to watch Rugrats as a kid you think I've
had sex some I kill him and I said have
another suicide for Kurt and
named RAM here Willie well they shot
themselves because they were gay lovers
and they couldn't take this judgmental
world any hunk
one of the best lines in the whole movie
is this the two cops come up after it
makes C and those they're awesome
especially the one that runs after them
why suicide why and then he pulls out
like a sparkling mineral water and he's
like does this answer your question
because gay people oh he drinks
sparkling mineral water then at the
actual best line of the movie my son's a
homosexual and I love him I love my dead
gay and their coffins are together
customers so Martha tries to kill
herself
and that's when Veronica starts to
realize like oh shit this is affecting
people so like it would happen in real
life
I knew Heather lead Heather emerges out
of the old Heather's so JD is like wet
scalar executors like no this is over
we're done jb3 murders is enough so she
pretends to hang herself the only
obvious solution and he comes in like a
little villain that he is and explains
his entire dastardly plan to blow up the
whole football it's like seriously like
villain monologue it is awesome
I wrote she reveals he is going to blow
up the school dude is nuts
I was right not to have a crush on him
at the beginning of the movie he tries
to stop him from blowing at the school
and she's like pointing a gun at him and
I'm just like where are these guns
coming from if it were his gun or is
this just a gun that she had why do all
these kids have done and then there's
some force kissing that I don't love she
stops the bomb and she's like you know
what I want babe cool guys like you out
of my life she makes like new faces it
Oh Winona Burrell one of those faces
girl she like survives and then then
just takes one bomb and puts it on self
and like walks outside then it stops
counting down because I have to hit it a
few times but she pulls out a cigarette
like let's say explosion light it and
it's so great and then she goes and
takes to the bow tie from the popular
jerk Heather and then like hides around
her head and she's like there's a new
Heather queen or whatever she says she
goes and apps Marth it out for prom is
awesome not what I thought was going to
happen I cannot believe that it wasn't
ruined for me at some point interrupted
I've missed out of it my love so good at
movies and trivia and pop culture I love
the family dynamics with Veronica's
family and had pretty much the same
conversation every time I loved that
they were all three named Heather I also
loved that the teachers had some form of
Pam in there named Pam and Pamela I
guess those really only two that I heard
but I think that's what they were going
for super funny Lhasa homophobic
language like a lot using the word fag
which I hate that way at what point is
it funny at what point is it not funny
and I found this funny it's kind of like
Blazing Saddles where you have like this
these awful words that they're using it
is awful racism but it's because it's
making fun of the people using those
words not the work yourself so that's
interesting and cool aspect of it that I
really enjoyed those hilarious the last
words that I wrote or just yeah next
week I am going to tackle quite the
classic I am going to Castle rocky one
and I'm gonna have Walter with me
because he is like a Rocky fanatics fan
I have no interest in the Rockies breeze
don't down WAP it but I said that I
welter I know your ending alright well
see you guys next week
[Music]
[Applause]